the 70s comic line that nearly destroyed
the company the video game that ruined
superman and the justice league movie
that's even worse than the one you're
thinking of what's went wrong with these
astounding dc failures keep watching to
find out
for comic books the 1970s brought with
it a maturation in both content and
storytelling that drove sales wild no
longer intended only for children those
who grew up reading comics found they
could still enjoy them while
simultaneously introducing them to their
own kids with this success came
expansion but dc's attempts to
capitalize and finally eclipse their
chief rival marvel comics nearly
destroyed the company in 1978 the
company announced a dc explosion a
marketing and publishing campaign that
sought to increase their market share by
publishing more ongoing series the
effort had actually begun three years
earlier from 1975 to 1978 dc comics
added 34 new titles to their line of
comics however two horrific winters back
to back in 1977 and 1978 devastated
supply lines decimated sales and further
exacerbated already rising production
costs dc comics was forced to cancel
over 30 of their ongoing series and been
nearly a dozen more still in production
nearly bankrupt dc was also forced to
lay off a percentage of its staff when
all was said and done their explosion of
new titles in 1978 ultimately became
anything but giving rise to the name
this event is still known as to this day
the dc implosion
joss whedon's live-action justice league
film was divisive to say the least but
it was a vast improvement upon the
closest thing it had to a precursor
cbs's 1997 made for television justice
league of america movie it was meant to
act as a pilot for a full television
series but the movie's abysmal quality
ensured that would never happen this
version of the superhero team included
the flash green lantern the atom martian
manhunter fire and ice their uniforms
look like cheap store-bought halloween
costumes and though the story ostensibly
centers around the team's fight against
a super villain named weatherwizard the
movie spends most of its time pretending
to be a standard 90s sitcom one that
just happens to feature superheroes did
you at least try to get him to fix the
tv barry's had a lot on his mind lately
he'll get a place as soon as he finds a
job
the team all live together in the same
building and the majority of its runtime
is devoted to their attempts to navigate
their underwhelming personal lives as
they fail at both life and love the
movie also frequently cuts away from
whatever is happening on screen to show
random interviews with their heroes in
their civilian identities a quirk that
would later be vastly improved upon by
the office
all in all this is hardly dc's finest
hour
in 1999 video game developer titus
interactive released superman at the new
superman adventures for the nintendo 64.
despite the wordy redundant title the
game is more commonly known as either
superman 64 or the worst video game ever
made gamespot gave the game a 1.3 out of
10 and said that it serves no purpose
other than to firmly establish the
bottom of the barrel ign's review
meanwhile flat out told its readers do
not buy this piece of garbage the game
was broken from the ground up the
controls were unintuitive difficult to
handle and often simply didn't work
making the harshly timed flying
sequences almost impossible to navigate
it was also plagued with bugs that would
commonly result in lagging stuttering
frame rates the graphics which were bad
even for the time often made it
impossible to see thanks to the thick
fog that constantly surrounds the player
basically even if the game did somehow
work properly players still had to fly
blind with a character they could barely
control in a timed race that had to be
executed perfectly in order to win and
that was just the first level
in 2004 halle berry became catwoman in
theaters across the world except for one
problem she wasn't anything like the
character fans had been reading about in
comic books since 1940 this wasn't
selena kyle it was an original character
named patience phillips she wasn't a
fiercely independent career criminal or
cat burglar she was a shy timid fashion
designer who discovers a dangerous plot
to release a deadly skin cream where
still patience shares none of her
inspirations anti-hero qualities and
instead becomes a straightforward hero
in one of the most poorly designed
costumes to ever plague the silver
screen perhaps unsurprisingly the movie
earned a 9 tomato meter and a razzie
award to boot
if there's a silver lining to how
divisive and controversial nearly every
single dc dceu film has been so far is
that previous entries like catwoman are
drifting further and further back into
the history books
to say that 2011's green lantern was a
mess is a bit of an understatement with
the mcu still fresh on the block the
movie was meant to serve as a foundation
for both its own trilogy and an expanded
dc cinematic universe it was a lot to
ask of a single film with an unproven
character and with a rotten 26 tomato
meter and a box office total that came
less than halfway to breaking even it's
safe to say it failed spectacularly
green lantern didn't so much tell a
story or roll out of plots as much as it
delivered nearly two hours of exposition
this ensured that anybody who stayed
awake throughout the whole film had a
solid primer for a hero that wouldn't be
returning to the silver screen any time
soon unfortunately even an impressive
cast wasn't strong enough to outweigh
the badly designed cgi green lantern
uniform or the hungry evil space cloud
that served as its main villain more
than a decade later green lantern is
primarily remembered for two things for
being the set where celebrity super
couple reynolds and blake lively fell
for each other and for being roundly
mocked by the deadpool movies
in 2006 snowblind studios released
justice league heroes for the xbox and
playstation 2. it was the team's first
full dedicated modern video game and it
was fairly well received then in 2009
global vr tried to capitalize on that
success by releasing a horrendous arcade
cabinet game titled justice league
heroes united this was a two-player
sequential hallway brawler populated
with character models that looked more
like oversaturated blobs though the
controls for the game were a nightmare
the most frustrating element may have
been a staggeringly frustrating third
person camera combined these elements
made playing the game a frustrating and
rewarding experience one that often left
players unable to actually hit any of
the game's enemies thankfully the
company's distribution model was just as
decrepit as a gameplay experience and
very few of the cabinets ever actually
made their way to arcades
when christopher reeve's first superman
film came out in 1978 it was a sensation
unto itself even to this day it is held
up as one of the best examples of a
superhero origin story the sequel
superman 2 was also a hit but the third
film in the series superman 3 was
received quite poorly not wanting to end
the series on a low note we've agreed to
do a fourth film but not before being
promised more creative control over its
story and direction inspired by
breakdowns in disarmament talks at the
time reeve wanted to do a story
revolving around the nuclear arms race
thanks to difficulties with multiple
directors however as well as a budget
that was suddenly cut in half right
before production began the movie that
released in theaters was nothing like
the one he had envisioned in short
superman 4 the quest for peace was a
mess the plot was nonsensical the
effects were terrible and the box office
revenue was barely enough to cover his
expenses let alone make a profit the
film killed superman movies for decades
and though fans today might be more
preoccupied by zack snyder's that would
take on the man of steel this
unfortunate mistake should never be
forgotten
batman and robin is not a good film in
fact it killed batman films for nearly a
decade and the director joel schumacher
was still apologizing for it decades
later seven million
never leave the cave without it
this movie was almost unbelievably campy
featured strange versions of too many
characters and was nearly universally
panned by critics and fans alike ice
machines are inexplicably powered by
diamonds thin plastic lip coverings are
enough to stop the world's deadliest
neurotoxins and the constant changes in
both costume and transportation were
included for no other reason than to
sell additional merchandise the movie
was a meager success at the box office
but it was clear that no one wanted more
of this version of batman still time has
helped this particular wound sting less
and less debates over more recent batman
have helped many fans forget batman and
robin and so bad as good movie watching
culture has helped the rest laugh along
if only to keep from crying
in 2007 dc comics decided to release a
wonder woman centric comic book
crossover event titled wonder woman
amazon's attack the story revolves
around the ancient amazons of themyscira
attacking the rest of the world it turns
out to be the plot of a shape-shifting
sorceress named cersei who has
manipulated the amazonians leader and
queen hippolyta but the war rages
nevertheless there were a key few
problems with this story however to
start where they barely featured wonder
woman at all as if that wasn't enough
the miniseries was a direct tie-in to
one of the most infamous comic books
that dc has ever published countdown to
final crisis one of the series few
trends was to show the amazons utilizing
all kinds of creatures from greek
mythology as magic war machines but the
cool factor is pretty thoroughly
nullified by the fact that the attacking
amazonian soldiers openly killed
children in the streets it's not a
particularly heroic moment for the
nation that gave the world wonder woman
surprisingly the horror story that is
all-star batman and robin the boy wonder
was somehow created by two of the most
beloved batman creators of all time jim
lee's art is famous across the comic
book industry for its stellar quality
and frank miller's earlier batman
stories are considered two of the best
ever written both batman year one and
the dark knight returns helps transform
the character into the brutal knight of
vengeance that fans know today but all
stars takes that trend to a painful
regrettable extreme this version of
batman is practically psychotic he
literally kidnaps dick grayson forces a
child to become robin and traps him
inside the bat cave with nothing to eat
but rats if that wasn't bad enough he's
also a sadistic monster who spends the
vast majority of his inner monologues
detailing the gruesome ways he's beaten
and crippled gotham's many criminals and
that's all on top of the series
cringe-worthy dialogue mind-numbing plot
and extraordinarily problematic
presentation of its few female
characters it's easily batman's worst
story ever and one that both dc comics
and its readers wish they could forget
thankfully time has helped this story
fade into relative obscurity made
forever stay there
josh brolin is famous among fans of
superhero cinema for his stellar
performances as sanos the arch villain
of the marvel cinematic universe's
groundbreaking infinity saga before he
wore that iconic purple chin however he
sported a half-burned face as jonah hex
in the 2010 movie of the same name in
the comics jonah hex is dc's most
popular western themed character and
thrives in stories set within that genre
but this movie was a long long way from
the good the bad and the ugly jonah hex
was a commercial and critical failure of
the highest order it made back only
one-fourth of its 47 million budget and
earned a 12 critical rating on rotten
tomatoes audience receptions weren't
much better due to its horrific pacing
and the strange unnecessary changes it
made to the character and his franchise
instead of being a gritty wild west
ranger this version of jonah hex had
magic powers that allowed him to
temporarily raise people from the dead
and instead of featuring in stories
revolving around the dangers of the
far-flung frontier this plot revolved
around a secret confederate plot to
destroy all of washington dc with a
giant cannon at the end the president
tries to make hex the sheriff of the
united states and that alone sums up
jonah hex rather perfectly check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about dc comics
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]